>>> A MODERN DAY WHODUNIT WITH
TWIST AFTER TWIST.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT "GLASS
ONION: A KNIVES OUMYSTERY"
STREAMING NOW ON NETFLIX I.
CHRONICLES AN ECCENTRIC
BILLIONAIRE INVITING HIS FRIENDS
TO A MURDER MYSTERY ON A GREEK
ISLAND.
>> ONE GUEST, JANELLE MONAE,
PUTS QUITE A WRINKLE WHEN SHE
ARRIVES.
>> CAN YOU SPOT THE OTHER THING,
THE REAL THING THIS GROUP HAS IN
COMMON?
>> RANDI, COME ON.
>> OH LIONEL, EVERYBODY KNOWS
WHO LIONEL WORKS FOR.
THAT'S NO SECRET.
WE KNOW WHO BANK ROLLED CLAIRE'S
CAMPAIGN, BUT WHEN NOBODY WOULD
TOUCH BIRDIE WITH A TEN-FOOT
POLE BECAUSE SHE WENT ON OPRAH
AND COMPARED HERSELF TO HARRIET
TUBMAN.
WHO DO YOU THINK SHOWED UP?
>> WE SAT DOWN WITH ACTRESS AND
MUSIC SUPERSTAR JANELLE MONAE.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WELCOME, WELCOME, WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME.
>> PEOPLE ARE FASCINATED WITH
THIS FILM, "GLASS ONION."
YOU'RE VERY INTENSE WITH IT, BY
THE WAY.
>> I REMEMBER BEING IN GREECE ON
THAT ISLAND IN A THAT VILLA, THE
WARMTH, BEING WITH MY CAST
MATES.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF MOVIE -- I
CAN'T TELL YOU THE AMOUNT OF
TEXTS I'VE GOTTEN FROM ALL MY
FRIENDS.
I'VE WATCHED IT WITH MY CLIDS,
MY MOM, MY GRANDPARENTS.
WHO DOESN'T WANT TO SERVE A
MURDER MYSTERY ABOUT A GROUP OF
RICH FOLKS GOING ON AN ISLAND
BACK STAPPING EACH OTHER.
>> I'VE BEEN OBSESSED WITH YOU
FOR A LONG TIME BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE FROM ATLANTA, SHE'S
OBSESSED FROM "GLASS ONION."
YOU HAVE TO INTERVIEW JANELLE
MONAE.
>> WHAT I LOVE IS YOU PLAY
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT CHARACTERS.
>> SPOILER ALERT, IF YOU HAVE
NOT SEEN IT.
>> CAN WE DO THAT?
>> SPOILER ALERT.
>> YOU PLAY DIFFERENT
CHARACTERS.
I KIND OF WHAT DREW YOU TO THAT
ROLE AND HOW IT'S DIFFERENT THAN
THE OTHER ROLES THAT PEOPLE KNOW
YOU AS PLAYING.
>> I PLAYED A CHARACTER THAT HAS
A LOT OF SECRETS.
WITH THAT AS AN ACTRESS, SUCH A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO -- YOU'RE
HIDING SOMETHING FROM THE
AUDIENCE AND THERE'S SO MUCH
DEPTH THERE AND SO MANY LAYERS
AFTER LAYERS AFTER LAYERS THAT
YOU HAVE TO PEEL BACK.
WHEN I READ THE SCRIPT, I WAS
BLOWN AWAY BY THE TWISTS, BY ME
PLAYING HELEN BRAND AND ALSO
CASSANDRA BRAND, AND PLAYING
HELEN PRETENDING TO PLAY
CASSANDRA BRAND BEFORE THE
AUDIENCE FINDS OUT AND HELEN
PRETENDING TO BE ANDI AFTER YOU
FIND OUT.
I KNEW IT WAS GOING TO BE A BIG
CHALLENGE IN THE BEST POSSIBLE
WAY.
IT WAS ESSENTIALLY LIKE FOUR
CHARACTERS.
I WAS REEDY FOR IT.
I WAS EXCITED.
I HAVE TO GIVE SO MUCH THANKS TO
WRITER/DIRECTOR RYAN JOHNSON.
THIS IS A CHARACTER HE CREATED,
EXCITING MURDER MYSTERY THAT HE
CREATED, AND FOR HIM AND DANIEL
TO HAVE ME ALONG FOR THIS RIDE
IS NO SMALL THING.
>> YOU'VE CALLED YOURSELF A
SELF-PROCLAIMED TRANSFORMER, AND
THAT YOU LOVE GOING OUTSIDE OF
WHAT YOU THINK YOU KNOW ABOUT
YOURSELF.
>> UH-HUH.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> YEAH.
MY WORD FOR THIS YEAR IS
DISCOVERY.
DISCOVER SOMETHING NEW ABOUT
YOURSELF.
THAT'S ALWAYS SOMETHING IN THE
BACK OF MY MIND, AS AN ACTOR, AS
A STORY.
WHEN EVER I'M TELLING STORY,
WHENEVER I'M CREATING ART, I
WANT TO PRESENT SOMETHING NEW
FOR MYSELF, FOR THE AUDIENCE.
>> CAN I JUST SAY PERSONALLY --
I THINK I MET YOU IN 2006.
>> OH, MY GOD.
IT'S BEEN THAT LONG.
>> IT MAKES MY HEART FLUTTER TO
SEE WHAT YOU HAVE DONE,
MOONLIGHT, HIDDEN FIGURES, GLASS
ONION, YOUR MUSIC, WHAT YOU'RE
DOING FOR FASHION AND ART IN
YOUR JOURNEY, IT'S AMAZING.
>> DID YOU EVER THINK JANELLE
MONAE WOULD BE THE JANELLE MONAE
SHE IS RIGHT NOW?
>> YOU BROUGHT BACK SO MANY
MEMORIES.
I THINK AT THAT TIME IN MY LIFE,
I THINK I MIGHT HAVE BEEN
SINGING ON THE CLUB WOODY STEPS,
SELLING CDs OUT OF MY TRUNK.
I REMEMBER WORKING HARD.
I'M HAPPY I HAVEN'T LOST THAT
WORK ETHIC.
YOU KNOW, I LOVE CREATING, AND
NO MATTER, JUST THINKING ABOUT
THE FILMS THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
IF IT HAD NOT BEEN FOR
"MOONLIGHT" AND "HIDDEN
FIGURES," I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
PREPARED FOR A ROLE OF THIS
MAGNITUDE.
I SIT IN GRATITUDE.
I SIT IN CONSTANT GRATITUDE.
THERE'S NOT A MOMENT IN MY LIFE
THAT I REMEMBER NOT BEING ABLE
TO SING OR ACT OR PERFORM.
MY MOM WAS ALWAYS TAKING ME TO
THE MUSICALS OR THE AFTER SCHOOL
SH
SHAKESPEAREAN PROGRAMS.
THINK FOR REMINDING ME OF THE
JOURNEY.
IT SEEMS LIKE I'M STILL ON IT.
>> AND SO GROUNDED, THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT PART.
>> SO EXCITING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE.
IT' AMAZING.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
GET SOME REST.
>> "GLASS ONION" STREAMING OF
NETFLIX RIGHT NOW.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.